bienvenue et merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de ces que de la télé
geneviève vous êtes médium vous
communiquer même avec votre défunt mari
je vous laisse vous installer
tranquillement
on rappelle que votre mari c'était le
chanteur michel delpech vous publié aux
éditions au pygmalion l'au-delà en
question et c'est étonnant
on vous cosigné ce livre avec un médecin
jean jacques charbonnier alors justement
la première question c'est que
normalement il ya une défiance entre la
médecine la science et et l'ameublement
de la médiumnité comment est ce que
c'est possible de faire collaborer un
médecin donc par définition un
scientifique cartésien avec une médium
je crois qu'on est dans un environnent
existentielle en ce moment avec la
physique quantique et toutes les
découvertes des univers parallèles et il
ya de plus en face il existe mais on
soupçonne de vraiment je pense que la
science s'ouvre de plus en plus
justement avec cette découverte de ces
découvertes de la physique quantique la
science s'ouvre de plus en plus à ce
phénomène d' irrationnelles dit pas
normaux et les scientifiques qui connaît
trop fermé et c'est d'aller de faire des
ponts et d'aller vers plus en plus j'ai
rencontré des astrophysiciens des
physiciens des médecins et je suis
surprise de voir à quel point il s'ouvre
avec les n2 aussi les expériences aux
frontières de la mort il se pose des
questions on s'en pose depuis toujours
et il saura plaire c'est ce qu'on
appelle l' émir des expériences c'est à
dire les expériences proche de la mort
des gens qui disent qu'ils sont revenu
d'entre les morts et qui nous raconte
cela est ce que vous comprenez tout de
même que malgré tout ça et il est malgré
même votre collaboration avec les
médecins scientifiques est ce que vous
comprenez que l'on doute de votre
capacité vous et d'autres à entrer en
contact avec l'au delà
bien sûr que je comprends je comprends
parfaitement que mais vous savez quand
ma grand mère vivait ne savais pas qu'il
y avait des milliards de galaxies
aujourd'hui on en est plus que sur anti
rien on va découvrir des tas de choses
mais je comprends il faut rester humble
et on je pense qu'on ne sait pas
grand-chose et j'accepte tout oui mais
je n'ai pas rencontré beaucoup de
d'agressivité mans patron et non
franchement alors je ne vous cache pas
qu ils sont plongés dans votre livre
avec des
tu as you énormément de questions à vous
poser on va commencer par thibault alors
vous dit notamment que vous communiquer
avec les morts ça me fascine mais
expliquez nous comment ça se manifeste
ce qu'il ya des flashes des voix des
portes qui claquent des tables qui bouge
je lui dis comme ça c'est vrai que ça me
fait rire mais oui gg de la clé audience
je les vois aussi au pied de mon lit
quotidien ça va dire salon la glaronaise
d'autres tentent toujours de lloret
gauche va pas toujours 7h11 en temps
mais en général les défunts qu'il ya un
affect souvent et un rapport affectif
avec les défunts que je voi à la plupart
du temps et c'est souvent trois mois
après leur décès et ils me disent
presque tous la même chose et si bien qu
est ce qu on leur demande qu'est ce que
tu as fait pour de tes frères humains
pour l'humanité mais il sans jugement et
ils sont heureux ils sont épanouis
je vais vous dites les manifestations
sont à la fois auditive c'est à dire
qu'il vaut murmure à l'oreille
oui et en même temps vous avez une
manifestation au pied du niveau dit oui
les voies savez j'ai conscience je porte
un nom le suit michel we qui était un
homme respecté et aimé et je suis
consciente du poids que ça représente
pour pour affirmer ça aujourd'hui c'est
pas si simple mais oui je vois des
défenses vous dites en septembre il se
manifeste essentiellement c'est ma vie
depuis l'enfance vous dites qu'ils se
manifestent essentiellement donc trois
mois après leur décès doit générer près
votre votre votre époux se manifester
auprès zoom j'avais pas sur les déficits
et à trois mois mais oui oui je t'ai vu
une seule fois vraiment vu une seule
fois mais je suis en contact avec lui il
ya eu un passage à vide j'étais dans ce
que j'appelle un vide sidéral et à
nouveau je suis en contact avec lui me
guident et savez il faut arrêter les
poncifs je crois il n'y a pas de repos
éternel on ne dérange pas les morts ils
sont simplement dans une autre dimension
un univers pareils à nouveau six mois je
vous opposiez toutes ces notions là
nouveau six mois je vous oppose de façon
très cartésienne en disant vous étiez en
deuil vous aviez tellement vie bien sûr
vous vous êtes persuadé peut-être de le
voir ou de l'entendre non oui bien sûr
chambre on me dit souvent ça mais non
non parce que j'ai des messages qui
répondent à des questions j'ai des
contrôles à la lisez mes livres
on la luz 2 - caroline alors caroline
est acquis à votre cause oui elle qu
elle vous qu'elle vous croit
complètement lg un témoin effectivement
je pense que c'est possible mais du coup
est-ce que vous conseilleriez aux gens
qui perdent des proches
une maman et un papa voilà quelqu'un
quelqu'un de proche d'entrer en contact
avec l'au delà est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui apaise vraiment les gars suez
victimes
c'est ce que je vous disais il ya
quelques secondes il faut arrêter ces
ces clichés quand il faut pas toucher
aux défend on les dérange a cessé on
subit les dictats des religions mais ils
sont dans une autre dimension il demande
que ça nous à nous parler krishnamurthy
lisais je suis simplement passer dans la
pièce à côté c'est ça mais ça marche à
tous les coups
non mais vous sûr ça ne marche pas pour
tout le monde et ça marche pas à tous
les coups mais comment est-ce que
pardonnez moi ma vive je me mets à la
place d'une maman qui aurait perdu un
enfant ou d'une scie qui a perdu son
père voilà comment est ce qu'on peut
éviter que ils ne tombent parfois
malheureusement ce que ça existe sur des
charlatans qui vont bien s'utiliser la
douleur en disant moi je vais vous faire
parler à votre enfant ou moi j'ai
l'écriture automatique voilà ce que
votre enfant physique c'était comment
est-ce qu'on peut par l'humilité par la
sincérité par l'honnêteté ne pas
répondre systématiquement à toutes les
questions quand on voit on voit quand on
voit pas en voit pas c'est vrai qu'avec
ce dont ses pantalons avec ce dont peut
avoir un ascendant dangereux sur les
autres il faut garder de toute façon
c'est la grande leçon de la vie
d'humilité 1 mais ça peut aider il faut
et délaisser le père brune qui m'a
demandé de témoigner pour aider
justement les gens jettent un audacieux
christophe oui vous aider vous
travaillez avec la police oui on a fait
appel
alors d'abord depuis qu'en fait-on apple
avouer qu'elle a quelques affaires avez
vous résolu si vous en avez résolu alors
ça fait une vingtaine d'années à peu
près que je travaille pour la police
directement ou indirectement parfois sol
c'est la famille elle-même qui
m'appellent là on vient de m'appeler de
birmanie et je me suis appliqué ces
cerises et enfin comment savoir si vous
aviez résolu des affaires
oui messieurs gérard mesures avaient
retrouvé des jambes il est bien sûr oui
mais reçoit ce sont par donnez moi votre
troupe des scouts général ce sont deux
des disparues des élèves
man des enfants des adultes c'est la
publicité acquis qui vient avoir eu
jean-louis bien sûr je viens de dettes
quotas enfin il ya quelques mots ça me
gêne de donner des noms mais sans donner
de précision sur des actes a encore
maryse avant je reviens de caen où là
c'est la gendarmerie qui m'a contacté
effectivement qui me fait témoigner
alors jeté mon jeu je suis dans un
bureau avec les gendarmes ou la police
ça dépend et ils me demandent de leur
dire ce que je vois parfois il mène sur
le terrain
et oui je trouve ça ne marche pas
toujours non ça marche pas toujours
c'est tout simplement parce que parfois
on trouve pas je vois un lieu je vois
des détails une cabane choses comme ça
mais on le retrouve pas et ça c'est
douloureux
c'est douloureux mais j'ai quand même
devant résultats justement donc vous que
vous considérez que ce que vous avez
c'est un don ou un fardeau les jeux les
vues longtemps comme un fardeau les a
nettement et je le vois comme un nom
surtout pas comme un talent maintenant
oui dans la mesure où je peux aider les
gens doivent comprendre tous
on termine avec avec amélie cas une
question à vous poser alors geneviève
donc vous le dites vous avez ce don ce
don de voyance de flash oui moi j'ai
envie de vous poser une question un peu
personnel je ne sais pas si vous allez
pouvoir le faire là comme pas mais moi
j'observe que nous sommes d'accord mais
est ce que vous auriez est ce que là
vous avez un flash en voyant est ce que
vous dites
elle va rencontrer quelqu'un a retrouvé
l'amour
quel est mon futur est flou alors
d'abord sa joie pas je vous voyais je
vois les événements plutôt graves de la
vie sage et leurs jeux verts eelv à dire
où les naissances ou les morts mais où
la mort mais je vois pas ça j'en ferai
un métier je vous ferai payer pour ça
franchement je vois pas comme ça
grâce à vous voyez rien demandé moi mais
je vous que vous êtes ravissante que
votre banquier j'ai fait du gringue
jean talon est bureau 200 kg et si
claude yoshizawa nantes
mais le gars tu vas te souhaiter que les
agios et compagnie moi je crois que
merci infiniment
joseph deiss a décollé avec jean-charles
lui longuement question bien évidemment
si vous avez des questions et bien ils
gagnent les réponses en tout cas la
vérité de geneviève delpech
à vous de vous faire la vôtre